cuando yo era pequeña fue con mi padre a
una tienda de bicis necesitábamos
arreglar una de las llantas en bicicleta
y empezó a hablar mi padre con él con el
dueño de la tienda y empezaron a
discutir sobre si los jóvenes íbamos a
cambiar el mundo a mejorar nuestro
nuestro presente
o no o por el contrario para nada mi
padre sostenía que sí que él estaba
invirtiendo en nosotras nuestra
educación para que construyéramos un
mundo mejor y el dueño de la tienda pues
decía que no que no se lo creía que eso
era muy difícil y que nos ha cambiado el
mundo que bueno deberíamos
y efectivamente no hay que cambiar el
mundo es muy complicado por donde
empezamos
yo os voy a contar algunos prototipos y
algunos proyectos que realmente creo que
tienen impacto y que han tenido impacto
el primer proyecto al que has de hablar
tiene relación con la calidad del aire
hace 7 años cuando nadie hablaba de
internet de las cosas de objetos
conectados nos embarcamos en un proyecto
para diseñar un dispositivo que pudiera
llevar en la mano y que me diera la
calidad del aire
lo desarrollamos en red con otros
equipos que estaban en nueva york y en
ámsterdam y el gran aprendizaje o el
gran descubrimiento de este proyecto fue
entender que yo era una ciudadana del
mundo que mis intereses y mis mis
problemas eran los mismos que las
personas con las que estábamos
trabajando en nueva york y en ámsterdam
y lo mejor de todo que el producto el
prototipo que desarrollamos no podía ser
mejor era una pasada de lo bien que
funcionaba porque estábamos teniendo en
cuenta toda una diversidad de opiniones
y de vivencias de gente muy diferente y
ese fue el gran aprendizaje de este
primer prototipo la diversidad es un
valor
y también dentro de este proceso otra de
las cosas que más me impactaron fue el
la potencia que tenemos las personas
cuando estamos juntas trabajando sobre
con un mir con un objetivo común y la
importancia del liderazgo transmitiendo
esos esos objetivos para aunar esfuerzos
en este proyecto en madrid en aquel
momento estoy hablando de 2010-2011 no
había espacios nos dimos cuenta que para
hacer este tipo de proyectos de producto
de prototipo transformadores en red
complejos necesitábamos una
infraestructura un espacio en el que
poder reunirnos prototipar con
diferentes herramientas digitales como
la impresión 3d para materializar
nuestras ideas
y poner en marcha estos productos que
realmente pensamos que pueden cambiar el
mundo
así que nos juntamos varias personas con
intereses comunes en madrid y promovemos
la creación de un espacio maker
y este espacio consiste en un taller un
taller del que cualquiera se puede
apuntar y venir a desarrollar sus
proyectos que ahora mismo llevan más de
cinco años funcionando
en el que tenemos cortas de las clases
impresa las tres y diferentes
herramientas de prototipado rápido para
que cualquier inventor o persona que
tenga una idea la pueda materializar
tenemos como os comentaba impresoras 3d
y sobre todo de nuevo personas una
comunidad de
gente super implicada de inventores de
creadores que dedican su tiempo a que
este espacio exista
y hace dos años cuando esto ya llevaba
un tiempo funcionando y ahora somos más
éramos más de 70 de 70 personas que
formamos parte de esta comunidad que
usuarios del espacio maker
y de la reflexión sobre qué tipo de
personas iban por el espacio y pues
éramos sólo dos mujeres
entonces bueno pues un paso atrás dije
que está pasando
qué está ocurriendo todo esto que ya
había aprendido mi primer prototipo de
la importancia de la diversidad y todo
lo que había aprendido trabajando con
gente diferente que está pasando aquí no
y empecé a investigar y efectivamente en
el sector tecnológico en el sector
digital en el sector y la presencia de
mujeres es muy baja
entonces sólo por recordar a las mujeres
somos el 50 por ciento de la población
somos el 50 por ciento del talento
mundial y este sector como comentábamos
antes
la tecnología impacta nuestras vidas y
la tecnología cambia y crece de manera
es potencial
entonces a mí me gustaría que la próxima
revolución tecnológica la lidere de
equipos diversos la líder en equipos que
representa de esta sociedad y que haya
mujeres en esos equipos
y al ver esta situación y con todo el
aprendizaje anterior decidimos que era
momento junto con otras personas que
pensaban como yo de montar una
organización y empezar a trabajar para
cambiar esta situación porque realmente
los servicios y los productos
tecnológicos estarán al servicio de la
sociedad si están diseñados por por
equipos diversos y tienen en cuenta
todas las realidades y las vivencias de
cada uno de nosotros en nuestra
diversidad
y así empezamos a trabajar en varios
programas uno de los programas que
llevamos trabajando es fomentar las
vocaciones científicas en niñas entre
niñas entre 8 y 12 años lo que hacemos
son talleres con los que tratamos de que
cambien un poco y rompan con los
prejuicios que tienen sobre sobre este
sector sobre que no piensen que es con
sólo cosa de frikis
otro de los proyectos que realizamos son
diseñamos formatos eventos situaciones
en las cuales damos visibilidad a
mujeres del sector tecnológico y digital
de forma que invitamos a las chicas que
estaban diversidad y están empezando a
que no se bajen del carro a que sigan a
que a que vean que hay mujeres como
ellas que están en posiciones de
carreras y avanzadas y que se han
mantenido en el sector y hay uno de los
de los eventos más gorditos y también
más ilusión me hace contar fue este que
hicimos en el espacio maker que os
comentaba antes entonces pasamos una
foto en la que prácticamente solo había
chicos como os comentaba a usuarios a
diseñar varios formatos trabajar la
comunicación y encontrarnos con esta
situación
con un entorno mucho más inclusivo y con
un entorno donde todas las personas son
bienvenidas para descubrir el potencial
de estas tecnologías
y materializar sus ideas y convertir sus
proyectos en realidad
entonces para terminar me gustaría
incidir en mis aprendizajes que
básicamente ha sido aprender haciendo
prueba hazlo con otros descubre y
aprende sus limitaciones aprende de las
experiencias de las personas con las que
con las que vas a trabajar y os animaría
que
como queráis todas las ideas que tenéis
ahora todos los proyectos los pusieras
en marcha o se atreviera a cambiar el
mundo y que podamos ir a hablar con él
con el dueño de la tienda de mi barrio
del taller de bicis y decirle que que no
que estamos aquí que se equivoca que
estamos aquí para cambiar el mundo y que
tenemos un montón de ideas y de
proyectos que van a dejar
el mundo la sociedad mucho mejor de lo
que está